Before I invite Tina up.
I'd like to tell you a little
bit about her experience.
She has over 20 years of experience
working with children and families and is
the current parent trainer for the early
early support program for autism and
four d RTP research program in the past.
She was the director of the Easter Seals
Bay area autism program as well as the
director of the Pacific Autism Center
for education and early intervention.
And she's also completed trainings with
multiple developmental based approaches
and has trained and supported
teams of developmental therapists,
behavioral interventionists and teachers
to develop successful programs for
children on the autism spectrum.
Join me in welcoming Gina stage.
Oh,
thank
you.
I'm happy to be here.
Thank you all for attending
and all those remotely.
So I have packets here today and I'm
just going to point out a few things.
What I'm currently doing is the
early support program for autism.
It's called s spa.
Awesome.
And I want to point this out ahead of
time because I certainly will go through
um, some resources at the end.
However you could call s Ba.
It's completely free at any time
and ask questions and get resources.
And this is a collaboration between
Stanford Children's Health Council.
You'll talk to Christina,
it's done in English and Spanish.
It's 100% free.
There's no boundaries when it
comes to where you're located,
the age of the individual you're calling
about or what resources we've had.
Um, infants come through, uh,
with parent concerns up to adults
calling for themselves to get resources.
They may not always get directed to
me for the parent training piece.
However, we do find resources, um,
and back way to parent
co call from Florida, uh,
for resources for her daughter who attends
Stanford as a sophomore who is on the
autism spectrum.
And so whatever calls we get,
Christina will seek
out information and uh,
and then she'll also tell you about any
research going on if you're interested
in research programs with
Stanford or elsewhere.
And also if you're interested
in this parent training,
it's a one on one parent training with
me. It's done over four sessions. It's,
there's no time constraints to this.
You can do it remotely or in person.
And again, it's 100% free.
And did we, based in,
because it's one on one,
we talk about your child and techniques
to help in any given situation with your
child and your family as a whole unit.
And then there's other in here.
What about additional free
classes that CMHC offers?
Um, and, and Christina can even speak
on those if you have any questions.
So I'm going to get into this a
PowerPoint and typically it takes me,
um,
more than an hour.
And so if I don't get through every slide,
don't worry about it because
there is overlap and this,
and I don't typically
stick to the slides anyway.
So this is just a lot of information
about children's health council.
And you can look at that,
uh, at your convenience.
We're going to talk about a child's
success and looking at it from a
developmental approach.
Um,
and we will look in particular
at the interactive environment,
how to create a successful environment
for both you and your child to connect
and stretch their skills and then
creating opportunities and finding those
teachable moments. And
for parents, especially,
it's about finding those
moments throughout the flow
of the day where when you
have programs set up,
they'll do more intensive stuff.
But certainly these techniques are
really important to know. Um, and to,
to hold everyone working with your
child to a high standard of, um,
getting these individually,
these opportunities to teach and teaching.
So when we talk about creating
an interactive environment, it,
it's really pivotal.
If we want success,
we set a child up for success
and success does build success.
So the more opportunities
they have to be successful,
and sometimes we call it the,
the preemptive strike,
we're going to call it
success before it is.
We create that confidence and
we can keep building on it. Um,
but in setting up the
environment for success, again,
for both you and your child.
And so we look at the yes items
and those are the teachable items.
The no items or our conversation stoppers,
they stop and interaction.
And so yes,
items are redirection.
It's our items we can say
yes to and then teach.
And you know, we, I look, we've worked
with parents to find these in everything.
And so for,
if I'm working with a child in a room,
the child doesn't know me and sometimes
we'll go to the door and you'll see this
later in the slide.
I really want to be a good audience to
receive all of the child's communication.
And when they don't have the language,
I put the language to it. However,
I'm going put all my energy
and excitement to my yes item.
So if they try to open the door and I
said, oh, not time flat affect flat tone.
I say not time to open the door yet,
but we can open bubbles, we can open,
played out in all my energy goes to my
yes and my excitement goes to my yes.
I'm not going to spend a lot of time
explaining and no a way like don't touch
that. No, it's not time to go outside.
We could do that later
because what happens is it's,
it's even as an adult when we hear no,
it's a bit of a staying and we're
listening a little less right. For kids,
they almost grab on to that
what they were working towards,
that no item a little harder.
And that's where we see the fits are,
that's where we see, um, not really
interacting with you so much,
especially if we're constantly,
oh no, don't do that. Nope.
Take it out of your mouth. Oh No,
don't touch that. Well, we're,
we're not really interactive
where the no person,
so we want to find the yeses in,
in as much as possible in these
situations. I do teach no,
but tick typically it's in an interaction.
It's in a game. If I say, you know,
is the ball over on the chair?
And I said no with huge
gestures and a big response,
really obvious gestures, a
point and everything else. Um,
and then when I buy a third time,
I always find it's my, yes, yes.
Um, so we really want to find those yeses
and, and keep away from the nose. If,
if it is a no flat affect,
flat tone,
we don't want to give a lot of
energy towards it. No. You know,
with kids in general, whether
there's a diagnoses or not, uh,
that energy gets a response.
So if it's a exciting no or an
exciting yes, it doesn't matter.
So we want the yeses to be
where our excitement goes. Um,
providing interactive items.
So we want to look for items that create
back and forth because the teaching
comes through connection. And then
that, so social loops of interaction,
you know,
teaching an isolated ways does work.
We don't always see it generalized into
other environments or with other people.
And so in these, uh, this approach
that I'll talk about today, it's,
it's really looking at the everything
being taught through loops of interaction.
Because the ultimate goal is for this
individual I'm working with to go and
share these tools with their peers,
not with me or not with other,
what we call manual,
a predictable in their control.
Adults. That'll be in the slide too.
Um,
so interactive items,
and I know that Google, however, we
stay away from tech as much as possible.
I can't be as exciting as
tech. Right? The, the what?
Everything I'll ask you to be
today is what kids get from,
you know, what they're watching
on youtube or in video or um,
the songs and dance and
all that colorful stuff.
Certainly there's things
we can teach to that,
especially for watching as well
and doing some pausing and kind of,
um, acting it out or asking
questions. But it is limited.
Uh, we want, we don't want,
we get rid of our competition.
So tech would be my competition.
I want items that I can bring the fun too.
It's not the object is
there to support the play.
However the person is the primary focus.
Uh,
that object is not fun
without me involved.
So you're looking for items that
don't have the bells and whistles,
the lights and the, the noise
is the battery items. Um,
so ideally really basic toys.
I like items like a,
what's called ICOM,
a poll tube and you just pull
it along and you can spin it.
You can do all kinds of stuff.
So thinking of items that you can get
a child excite to look you're way more
often and wants you to do it again.
And again to promote functional language,
um, creating an interactive environment.
Again, be a good sensory detective.
So typically when I do this talk,
I do this kind of experimental or I try
to give you some type of taste of what
sensory may be going on with the child
and we're always doing our best guests
because we cannot say
what affects a child.
We can observe and we can make
best guesses. Um, however,
when we're talking about
young kids in general,
we know that their sensory
system is immature.
When we're talking about child who's not
hitting all those milestones the way we
expect them to, we're going to
kind of guess that there is some,
there are some interruptions
and their sensory development.
And so being a good sensory detective is
investigating the environment setting.
Again,
the environment up for success is getting
rid of items that are going to be an
issue. So I work with a little boy now
who will mouth a lot of soft plastics.
I don't bring soft plastics into the
session. I'll bring hard plastic toys.
I bring items that I
can create interaction,
but I am not going to spend time
taking things out of their mouth.
I also will make sure there's a
replacement for items like that.
So if a child is mild thing
for being a sensory detective,
I view that as there's a need there.
And as a responsible adult I need to
help that child meet that need so they
don't have to keep seeking out
items to meet it themselves.
And so replacement, yes items is
really important. Um, you know,
having,
you know,
your work with an occupational therapist
may end of times they'll use it to a
chewy and uh, you know,
some kids do well with that,
some don't or they get bored after a
while. So they'll do it for a little bit,
but they'll still grab the other items.
Having other items that
might provide more input. Um,
dish wash cloth, a dry
wash cloth, does that,
cause they can get it back into
areas that a chewy doesn't get and,
and it kind of can, it's more
malleable. It can get into,
it gets wet and then you can
move it around a lot more.
It's an acceptable item. Um, some,
I know parents who have
done handkerchiefs,
so they're always accessible that way.
So looking for again, yes items even,
um,
teething rings still.
I mean when they come out of the freezer
sometimes that can give a nice relief
or whatever's going on and you know,
also trying lots of
different pressure and areas,
which if you work with a
good occupational therapists,
they work a lot on the sensory system too.
And they'll put a child on
what they call a sensory diet,
which is deep input, different
type of movements for development.
Um, you also want to make changes to
the environment. Again, you know, if a,
if a child get rid of the no items,
but also if,
if the law and you have great lights
here, in fact, part of my, um,
experiment I do is the shaking the
lights and off and on and shaking a bag,
making lots of noise and it drives
most parents crazy and you can't focus.
And I said, that's a little
taste of what may be going on,
that what you're asking out of your child.
They're filtering through all
those layers of, of sensory issues.
So yeah, it takes time to process.
If they could do it easily,
they would be doing it easily.
And so to acknowledge that it is hard
and so we need to set up that environment
to give as much success as
possible. Um, so you know,
having access to a
trampoline or being beggar,
even cushions for deep pressure or
being able to jump in on the bed, doing,
um, tight, uh,
rolling a child up in a blanket
tightly and back out, uh,
which we call a Burrito and kids love it
and we'd get lots and lots of language
out of activities like that because
number one, they can't do themselves.
We were, we have to be a
part of it. And number two,
it relaxes their body and gives
him the light blood, nice input.
And so they do what more and more.
So I keep stretching with as we
continue and I get them more engaged,
excited about their activity.
Um,
so you want to remove items
that are an issue, support,
sensory regulation.
You know,
if you look at activities online,
you just want to try different things
to really have a nice array of sensory
movement,
sensory input activities.
And it depends on what the
child is seeks out or voids. Um,
you know, again, there's a lot of good oh,
occupational therapists out there
and if you're not working with one,
their websites will give you a lot
of tips as well. You can also search,
which I've done many times to get ideas
as brain gym and then I'll just look at
the images under brain gym and he'll give
me ideas of helping a child move their
body in different ways.
So they are what they call crossing the
mid point and working both sides of the
brain. Um, things that when we don't do
for a while and then you try to do it,
you realize it's not
as easy as you thought,
like jumping jacks and then I'll
try to do, and I'm like, oh,
I think I forgot how to do a
jumping jack or jumping rope.
I'm skipping right. Sounds like no big
deal. If you haven't done it for a while,
try it. You'll realize your brain's lost
a little of that. You can get it back,
but it takes practice
and really paying attention
to the child's ongoing needs.
One of the things you want to
be as a good sensory detective,
there's just sit step,
you know,
step back and observe and observe the
finer details of what your child is doing
that you may want to
look for ways to support.
Because if we can't be a
partner in this, we can be, um,
play a role and the need to open and
shut a door and all of a sudden it's our
idea. Instead of US stopping
them constantly from doing it,
they're going to turn more and more to
you as a partner instead of somebody that
no person in that,
um, position yourself for eye
contact. You want eye contact,
make it really easy be at his or her
I love are lower and then capture it.
You'll see it later. And again, I jumped
around the slides, but reinforce it,
everything you want to see how that
child more often reinforce, oh good luck
and do it with that nice energy.
Um, but if, if, if you're,
if you're working or you have a child
who doesn't have nice eye contact and you
want it, set them up for
success, make it really easy,
take all the obstacles out of it and
then reinforce it each and every time.
And I know sometimes it's quick,
but I mean I will capture it con if I'm
working on it, I'll get it each time,
even if and moving and then I get to slow
it down a little bit more and a little
bit more.
Yeah.
Promote reciprocal interaction.
Again,
everything we teach through
loops of interaction.
And so you'll see it later in the slide,
but that pause is really important.
And for that anticipation of,
I know I'm going to get something back
and I'm available to receive it back.
Um, and you know, many times when I,
I'll work in a room with no distractions
and where I don't have to run after a
child a lot to get eye contact.
Um,
and so that way we can do a lot more
of the back and forth reciprocal
interaction.
She might look at space like that and
make it a space that a child wants to stay
in because it's so much fun because
you bring the fun to it. Um,
offer visual steps when necessary
and schedules. So, you know,
it's, it's more impactful of a
learning opportunity. If we see it,
we hear and we experienced it,
I have a better chance of
taking that skill with me.
So visuals are really important.
Whether I'm an actual item, uh,
icon, a picture of an item, or
I do it in gestures like, Oh,
do you want pizza or chicken?
And there's nothing there.
But it helps with visualization,
which helps with,
when kids do get into chapter books
and things like that, you know,
you have to be,
it's the same as social comprehension.
You have to be for reading comprehension,
able to visualize the characters.
Visualize the environment and then start
making predictions of what could happen.
And that's the same for that social piece.
That's why it's so hard.
There's all those unwritten rules
of what it means to socialize and be
successful.
Um,
and so you want to make it really obvious
and schedule sometimes help visual
steps help.
One of the things you want to be careful
is to do us too many schedules and then
you get a more rigid individual,
right?
We want flexibility within
those schedules. So if I
have a schedule planned out,
why it might have a special activity
in that. Um, you know, if you're going,
if you drive disk,
a child to school every day and you
have options to go multiple routes,
you want to take a left turn next time
instead of our right turn when you go on
walks. She wanted to explore, be
curious and go different directions. Um,
we can do a lot of flexible,
um,
demonstrations even with our speech.
So if I say go shut the door,
I can also say go close.
The door means the same thing
and people say it differently.
And so you want to vary your language,
uh, for Nice flexibility as well.
Okay.
When we're creating opportunities,
and some of this I'll go through in
more detail, you want to be manageable,
predictable in a child's control.
You know, the, the social world,
um, a lot of things in, in an
individual's life are not manageable,
predictable in their control. And
so it's scary and that's, and,
and especially if their sensory issues.
And so that's where you see a child runoff
or bite or hit wanting to get out of
what's a very scary situation.
Um, and so as adults,
we can be that.
Within that we can,
we will expect flexibility and we'll,
we'll try and challenge a
child in a healthy manner. Um,
and we'll go into that in more
detail and be irresistible, right?
Be the fun of the play and
make it obvious. You know,
what you're, what it looks like. Um,
invite your child to take
healthy risk. Uh, you know,
that's really important for them.
It's a little scary,
but if I can be manageable,
predictable, and the control and, and,
and give little pieces of a risk and risk
is very different for different kids.
I had a bean bag one time in a room
where a child does a lot of, uh,
really more academic work
and not the social piece.
And he sat in a beanbag and I thought,
oh,
I'm going to do a sensory
social activities, we call it.
And so I went and I picked the beanbag up.
You know,
I kind of gave pressure and I just
picked it up. I said, oh, oh, oh,
just to my knees. And he was
scared. And so I went down, down,
down, and I did not let go because I
knew he would be out of that bean bag.
And I know he'll enjoy it if he
can see that it is manageable,
predictable in his control that
is safe. So I do it again. Oh Oh,
ah, down, down,
down and again later in
slide always comes up for,
I have a very clear beginning,
middle and end to my routine and I'm
going to do it at least three times the
rule of three. If a child needs
it more cause I think, oh,
he still needs a little more,
he looks scared but he's starting to
relax and I'll do it more typically three
does it for me and I'll
do it again. Uh, oh, ah,
known down,
I put him down again and then I let go
and he stayed in and he actually set up
up, up. Right. So I do
it again up at this time.
I go all the way up and I go down and
we did a few more times and he tells me
up, up, up for more. It's a more, because
what I really want now is for him to say,
I have got them, I've captured them
into this activity. But now, uh, up,
is it really appropriate? You can tell
me more. That would be more appropriate.
So I say more and I do up, up, up,
and then I add something to it.
I had this spin and if I spend
a child one way, I always spin,
spin them the other way. Again,
it's more impactful for our child,
so if a child's running around a
lot or spinning, get them to grow.
Tate reverse.
I see reverse go the other way.
So I started teaching those
words by defining them.
At the same time we're doing them and
it's, they won't need as much spinning.
You know? Some kids can spin
constantly, get not get dizzy,
spin them one way and
spend them the other way.
Their bodies are impacted
in a more satisfactory way
and they won't need as much
spinning and stuff are running around.
It's hard to,
if a child's running in a circle and
you say, stop, reverse. I mean they,
they're in this momentum.
It's even a child without a diagnosis.
They have a trouble then going the
other way and I hold them to it.
Anything I ask of a child, I hold them
to it. Whether I helped them or not,
whether they do it independently or not,
doesn't matter to me,
but I do hold them to the expectation.
So they know that I'm always going to
hold you to these expectations and those
expectations. If this is where their
skill level is, I'm doing the next step.
I'm not leaping, you know, we're
not doing brain surgery now.
I want success.
And so it set next step.
MMM.
So this is a very healthy,
healthy risk for a child.
And I know he's going to love it.
And so I keep adding onto this activity.
You and I start teaching,
no, yes, in this activity.
Because if you give him
a choice or if I say,
do you want to go down? He'll say,
go down. He just repeats, right?
The last couple of words. Um, and
so I want him to say yes or no.
So I started teaching yes and no in this
activity, going up, doing some spins,
and it was in a playful way of,
instead of putting them on the floor,
I'd say down, down, down on the counter.
And that was a know that.
And so I would have again by three,
I was on down, down on the
floor. Yes, yes. And then I,
next time I'd say down,
down like on the chair and
I'd wait for him to answer no.
After I demonstrate it a few times and
then he would start, start to go, no.
I'm like no.
And then get to the yes item.
MMM.
By doing these things
again, being manageable,
predictable and its controller,
rarely much more interactive
partner in this and be responsive,
which is that thank you's.
And you'll see that in another slide.
So being manageable. These are some nice
questions to ask yourself. You know,
grabbing things out of a child's
hands, not manageable, uh,
moving too quickly.
You want that slow approach.
You want those pauses and ah,
and, and sounds and sounds,
your activities,
they know it's coming again with a child,
with the diagnoses are not my child. There
are other child doesn't matter to me.
I always do these type of techniques
and you get a more of a buy in by doing
these type of techniques. So, even if
I'm about to just tickle or something,
you know,
it's coming because you know,
ticklings one of those things that
there's a little bit of fun to it,
but mostly it's not a fun activity
because you get a kid's cracking up,
but you keep doing it and they've
already passed that enjoyable, um,
kind of fine line, but they're
laughing stills you keep at it.
Um, and so, you know,
being really manageable,
predictable in their control for
stuff like that. So you always,
I always show a child my approach like
you come to so he'd know it's coming.
They're cracking up from the anticipation
because it's much funnier than the
actual tickles. And they'll
say, ah, tickle, tickle,
tickle, and then right back up.
But, you know, I'm not too far where
if my approach is way over there,
it's not so much fun or if I'm too close,
it's a little scary.
It's really manageable.
Um,
and that anticipation is really
important for social anticipation.
Being able to read something,
anticipate what's going to happen
by reading the environment, the,
the body language, his facial
affect, the movements, um,
is so important for social success.
And we can teach that early
on with those pauses. Ah, ah,
you know, and have that sound to
it. And I'll even do multiply.
And you know,
kids think it's much funnier than if
I just went in and start tackling.
Plus you get a child looking
more and tracking. Um,
so either attending instead of just
getting the needs met and then being gone.
MMM.
You know, being really careful through
removing things from kids hanging. If I,
if a child is playing
with a car or something,
I'm going to join them exactly
what they're doing. However,
I'm going to have my own car.
I mean, won't personally be my,
I'll probably be another
one of his or hers,
but still I don't ever take
the child's item from them.
Even if I'm trying to demonstrate,
I do it by joining them and then offer
something in addition to what they're
already finding mastery and pleasure from.
Um,
being careful about standing
behind her above. I mean,
none of us liked somebody
too close behind us.
It's uncomfortable if I am behind a
child and I'm going to help them with
something, I put my hands out in front
and say, um, I'm here in my hands,
I'm going to help.
And then I might help them do hand
over hand or something like that.
Picking up a child. Same thing. Mine or
not, it doesn't matter to me. I'll say,
I'm gonna pick you up and I don't wait
for a yes or no. I might tell him,
why am I,
oh,
we're going across the big street and pick
you up and then I pick up or you know,
this car. So you have to hold
my hand and then I take him.
But I let them know
what's going to happen.
I make myself available and then
I have followed through to that.
Um, um, being, being
predictable again,
helping them anticipate what's coming.
And you do that with the pauses,
make sure they know what their role
is and what your role is in that.
So sometimes it's explicitly saying
that. And you know, as parents,
I think we all do this is we put things
in a question instead of a comment and
you know,
I know better to do that.
And I still seem to throw a question at
the end. I'll say, oh, time for bed. Okay.
And I think, why am I doing it?
Okay. It's not, I'm not asking,
I'm stating, um, and so
if you're not asking,
don't put it in a question
form when you say, Oh,
do you want to play or can I
play with you? I wouldn't ask.
You're gonna because you're
probably going to get a no.
Unless you're going to accept
that no walk away or let's try it.
You want to try it this
way? And then it's like, no,
well then I would join exactly
what they're doing and it's, Oh,
I'm going to try it like this. And then
you demonstrate what you're going to try.
But you want to make it
clear what's expect. No,
I can step up to an expectation
if they don't know what it is.
And so making that very clear,
what is expected with little
language and gestures,
right? Put you don't have
to explain things away.
What you want is that follow through.
And the more they can
follow nonverbal gestures,
the more they're watching.
And the more you're helping increase
their observation skills for observing
peers,
learning how to know what's
going on and that social setting,
which will help them know how to join
and maintain the social interaction.
Um,
and giving that time again with the
sensory issues that may be going on,
processing time is really
important. So if I say, Oh,
do you want water? And they
don't answer, I'm like,
water, do you want the water? Do you want,
you want a drink of water?
Each time I speak,
it's like starting all over.
So I ask and then they start processing
the information that I ask again.
It's like, okay, I start processing
again. Then yes, different ways to,
sometimes we touch, look at me,
which is very overwhelming, right?
Skins our largest Oregon
taking in stimulation.
And so then I've got a process
that in addition to you talking,
in addition to is maybe some demand you're
putting on me in addition to lights,
uncomfortable chairs, temperature,
whatever else is going on,
hearing a fan, um, you know,
we can all sit here and ignore
many things in tune in. Uh,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't assume your child can do that
and I wouldn't assume your child knows
what's expected out of them.
I was working with a little boy of the
day and he said something about soccer.
So I'm like, oh, I have an idea, you know?
And so I said, we had a ball and I say,
well, let's play soccer.
You're going to kick the ball.
And I'm the goalie and I have to stop it.
And he couldn't act on any of it.
And so I kind of made it really obvious
of what it looked like. And then,
and so his mom later told me,
he has no idea what soccer is or
anything else you just said. Well,
he's the one who brought it
up. So I, I assumed he knew.
And for all of these specialties,
social activities, even things like tag,
it seems like a pretty simple game.
But unless you play with your child and
you see that he or she knows all the
roles in it,
that you don't just keep running at you
actually tag and then you run away and
try not to be tagged again.
Who's it,
who's nodded what the rules are.
And they've gotten a lot more complicated.
Kids aren't just playing tag.
If you're at a playground,
you'll hear him make up
a lot of thematic play,
pretend play around tag. They'll
say like, if you touch the ground,
it's lava and your blah,
blah.
And it's all these rules now that make
it really complicated. So as you're,
as you're playing games like this with
your child, you want to start to make,
put kind of themes around it,
stories around it,
make it more complicated in a,
in a way that's manageable,
predictable in their control. And
B, again, being a good partner,
making it really obvious what their
role is and what your role is.
Um, making sure they feel in control
doesn't mean they get control. Um,
however,
helping them manage this,
uh, the scariness of it all and
giving them a sense of control.
So if they're,
whatever they're motivated by,
that's where we start when
we're connecting with the child.
And then we can add more things to it
that maybe are not where they're motivated
or maybe is it,
is it is not a preferred activity.
I can go in that direction. So as
I work with kids, I, it's, it's,
it's certainly child led.
So it's third agenda.
I had my goals and I never
get rid of my goals, however,
I start at their skill level,
their interests, and then
my steps to the goal is,
is in that direction and it's constantly
stretching and it's really layered
learning cause I'm getting eye contact,
I'm demonstrating what lots of Nice
facial expression, nice tone of voice.
Um, you know, whatever skill I'm
working with, if it's a concept,
if it's expanding on play and
I'm getting loops of interaction.
So it's not just me. Um, it's,
it's not just me meeting needs,
it's back and forth.
I'm being really,
and that's the whole sensory detective
is responding to their body language.
What is a child telling you? But
especially around that nonverbal language.
Um, so if a child pushes away, I'm about
to tickle and they turn their body,
I'll say all done tickler,
no tickle.
And if they come back testicle Oh,
more or whatever. Um, but I, I'm,
I'm very responsive to body language and
what that's telling me and I functional
language to that body language.
Okay.
Um, the toys, again, not
taking the toys away,
not withholding. You'll see it later.
You don't want to withhold items.
If a child saying, you
know, buck for banana,
I can work in and go in the
direction of the word banana,
but I'm not going to withhold that banana
until they say banana because I'm not
a good partner here.
I'm not user friendly.
They're gonna walk away
way before we get there.
And so being responsive as being
that user friendly partner.
Yeah.
Um, not to stop or interrupt,
play when plays going on.
We just want to keep expanding
on it and expanding on it
and again knows we'll stop it. Uh,
certain items being taken away,
stop it being irresistible.
The big expressions,
you'd draw attention their face. These
are the things to be socially successful.
And with social success we see
learners because they're observing.
They read the situation
and then they'll imitate.
They'll learn from what they're seeing,
the things we want them to imitate. Um,
and, and they start to learn from their
peers instead of having to be taught
directly. And so we want, again,
want to make it really obvious early
on with the exaggerated expressions.
Um, letting them see your face, pausing,
exaggerating your movement, uh, the,
if they're working on
point or whatever else,
make it really obvious what
that looks like. I mean, again,
you think it's no big deal,
but you know,
to learn to isolate this
finger amongst all of the rest,
it takes a lot of brain power.
The messages have got to get through our
bodies to isolate these motor movements
in. Sure. We do it all the time. That if,
if the messages aren't going
through your, you know, from your,
from through your body to the brain
and then back in a timely manner,
you're not seeing this.
And so you want to make it really
obvious of what it looks like.
Demonstrate it so that there's
no question of what's expected.
Um, sound draws a men even with
bubbles, if I say, you know, oh,
bubbles pop,
stuff like that, right? If all I do
is this, a child's not going to watch.
I want to tracking,
I want them invested in this activity.
I want them making sounds cause some
leads to language and what kids,
young kids especially do
is they put sound to play.
And so getting all those
sounds going in different ways,
whether it's jumping on
the bed or running around.
And a lot of times for kids,
if they don't have language,
and I put sounds to it,
they're able to initiate play with
me with the sound because they don't,
can't say, oh, I want you to do bubbles
for me again. They'll just stay.
Oh.
And I'll say [inaudible]
I give again,
give back the functional word for it,
but I accept the language they're
able to give me at that moment
and make that activity much more
fun with you than without you.
And that means being manageable,
predictable in their control.
Because when you're not, it's not fun
for them. You're taking away from um,
their activity,
the way they have to do it in that moment.
Can we join exactly what they have
to do and then I can stretch it.
But if I go and just decide a child who
is maybe spinning wheels and I go and
say, oh, that's not how you play with
car. Did you take the car and you go are,
or even if I make it fun, it won't matter.
This is where he is. He's mastered this.
It fulfills him in some way.
I need to respect that.
And so I joined an exactly that and
then I add to this, ah, you know,
go fast or slow. I do some concept
and I do the rule of three.
Would that beginning, middle and end
and say, you know, Gina's wheels,
I got to go fast, ready, set, go,
make it really obvious. And I go back
to joining at his pace and the old guy,
dude, his wheels are going again and I'll
do that same way at least three times.
And if he keeps looking,
I know he's interested and
then I want more out of him.
What I really wanted to imitation with
a little boy, I'm actually thinking of,
he didn't give me a mutation,
so I went back to joining.
He kept looking over and I'm still
here and I would just keep doing this.
And finally he said, Ma. And he
didn't have language. He had a pro,
a few proximation sets it
and lots of sensory issues,
low body tone and so on my own,
I'm actually on my stomach to be lower
than him and I'm doing exactly what he's
doing.
And so I give him exactly what he wants.
Um,
but only when he gives me
something I don't keep giving.
And then I go back to this and then
he looks up at me, does it get more?
And,
and after a couple of times like that,
I start to decrease my
party and give more words.
He'll say, if more. And I said,
well, you're really like fast. Okay,
here's more asbestosis pass.
Then I give them more.
And at some point I did prompt
them. And this is only, you know,
really within minutes this was happening.
First Time meeting him and I say,
Johnny do fast and he's doing this
and it was really at the same pace but
preempt a skirt strike. I say good,
fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast,
fast. And he started doing fast and then
that same, it was a two hour session.
Within that same tour session,
we ran fast, we jumped fast.
So we took the concept of fast and we did
it in multiple activities for mastery.
And then at some point we added slow to
activities where they were appropriate.
You don't want it to be,
I still make it fun.
And so if I do slow for certain
things, it's not so much fun. Um,
so that he could start
discriminating between these things.
Um,
be
responsive. That's that. Thanking him.
Everything you want to see out of a child,
you want it to be clear what's expected.
We can put that in our response,
our thank you's and vary your
language. Again, make it fun.
You want to keep that, that
value to it. So if I say, oh,
thank you for cleaning up.
Oh, thank you for eating.
Oh, thank you for sharing.
I'm going to be specific and say exactly
when I see more often because if a
child gives me something, I say
thank you. I can assume he knows,
but I don't want to assume I want to.
What I'm really saying
is do that more often.
Just like the kid who really didn't
do fast, but I said good fast. Right?
I'm telling him it's fast before it is,
but what I'm really saying is faster,
faster, more, more, more.
But I'm building that confidence and I'm
showing that we're a team in this and
so I can say thank you with
good energy and be specific,
but it loses its value after awhile. Sick.
Thank you all the time, kind of boring.
And you want to keep that value in that
kind of connection and doing things like,
oh, there's those pretty eyes.
Get excited about that stuff.
It also brings more energy as
you're doing these, you know,
when you think how long
do I do the eye thing?
Shouldn't he be giving me eye contact by
now if he's not, we keep reinforcing it.
Um,
and we keep the party hi when needed.
It's like when a child first starts
walking, right, we get really excited,
you can do it.
And we were kind of that big cheerleader
there and now that they have own
walking, we don't have to
say anything more about it.
We move on from those things.
But we have to be that cheerleader in
that development of whatever skill you're
looking at.
And you know,
the thing about eye contact is cause
there's a lot of kids who don't have to
look to take the information in.
However,
at some point they're going to be missing
the more complicated stuff because
they're not watching.
So we do need eye contact.
Um, you know, we want the,
certainly that receptive language that
follows it was very, very important. Um,
but I'd hold them to
the eye contact as well.
So finding teachable moments.
Those are just kind of some ideas.
I'm going to move on for this
just to get to the next slide. Um,
model functional language.
Again, be that good audience.
The more you receive communication
was verbal or nonverbal,
especially the nonverbal
to say back things even,
but she child looks a little nervous about
something. I know it's a little scary,
but I'm going to help you.
You could do it or hating haircuts,
hating to get their hair washed,
brushing teeth or whatever.
I know you don't like it.
It's okay. We can do it.
And you kind of let them
know first. You know, first,
you know, top teeth [inaudible]
Tepe than all down or something.
I'll do the washing hair
and I'll say like, you know,
five cups of water and then all done.
So I let them know,
I estimate what it's
going to take and then I,
I get it through and it's
not fun for the child.
However they survive it. And for
some things, that's what we're doing.
We don't want to tip tool around,
you know,
it's anxiety provoking activities or,
or,
or scary activities.
We want to help them through it.
We want to be a partner and
say, no, it's a little scary,
but when you think help you,
we would do it together and
then we give them some success
and then we move on to the next.
We don't have to spend again a lot of
time explaining why they had to do it.
We just want to help them be successful
and that in any given activity.
Um, and, and what happens too is
over time it gets easier and easier,
do less for the child, um, to
create openings. And again,
I, it, it, especially for help of a
child needs help. And it's obvious to me,
I am available and I'll put my
hands out and say, I'm right here.
If you want help and I'll punch out
whatever word they should be saying,
but I don't automatically
do. You know, I, I um,
right there,
it's,
I'm anticipating them giving me
something or asking me for help,
but they do have to give to get.
And so for kids who don't have language,
they might put the item in my
hand, I'll say yes, help, help.
And I help for other kids,
they might give me language to help or
for some I'm ready but they want to work
on a little longer and I might get
a little reinforcement for that.
And so your work, you're really
hard things, you know, again,
just reinforcing the actions they are
demonstrating to me with functional
language,
but keeping it really simple,
no matter how much it
language a child has,
I do a lot more gestures
than expansive language.
Okay.
Um, pause often you've
seen me do that. Um,
it allows a child to give,
to get,
it also allows them to read the situation
because at some point you want to be
yells at Johnny and he looks at it
and for follow through with things
like that. That's much more compliment,
complicate that made us say,
Johnny, come over here, have a seat.
I mean that's all first teach it,
but across the room you want to be able
to go like this. That's a more subtle,
a social language that
we all have to read. Um,
demonstrate nice social emotional language
and problem solving skills. You know,
it's really important for a child early
on to have social emotional language.
And so we do,
we teach that by giving it to them.
I know it's a little scary or oh,
that you know that they're sad
or whatever and be that yourself.
You don't always want to do
things perfectly. Have accidents.
All have a little water and a cup.
And I'll purposely,
it spilled for it depending on
the child and working at La.
Oh well I'll clean it up. Right?
Accidents happen. But for some kids,
you know, their social emotional
responses over the top.
And so you want to have a
little bit of a reaction, uh,
but then a problem solve the problem.
You don't always want to go to solving
the problem and you think about it in
your own life. If you came home
to your partner and said, oh,
traffic was so bad, I can't stand
one on one, it's always packed.
And they're like,
oh,
why don't you take one on one every time
I tell you to go blah instead of one on
one. You don't want a pro, you
don't want solution to that problem.
You're aggravate it and you want someone
to meet you there and the aggravation
and then you can let it go. But if
someone's always solving your problems,
you're not going to really talk to
them about problems so much. Right?
You just want to be matched
and then you can come down.
And so even for kids who
do have big responses,
I guess you all have experienced
this before. I'll match them in that,
but then I can bring him down.
Like if it's frustration,
I know it's so frustrating.
Hey, I have an idea, try this.
Right? But if I don't
match them there, then I,
I typically can't lead them
out of there. So, again,
depending on what your work on.
Um, so have your own accidents.
Try something and make it not work.
You know, doing household, uh,
you know,
fixing things around your house.
Kids love to try to do
screwdrivers or whatever.
Act like you can't do it and asked for
their help and make it really simpler.
Opening a water bottle, you
know, I'll purposely have
it loose. Can you, you know,
and I'll ask for them to help me.
And then they're able love when
you helped me write it, well,
I already loosened it up. It's still, um,
I make it so that I can't solve
everything. I can't do everything.
And so that they can step into,
we all need those moments.
Pair gestures with your
words, visuals, you know,
gestures are so important.
And so if you're not an expressive person,
you want to turn it on for those moments.
Be Mindful teacher.
You want to think about what
you're teaching and promote that,
especially imitation through
demonstration. When we look at imitation,
I don't think that's an it, but
we're looking at facial, um,
Volkl gestural action with objects.
Um, so you want to, and you want to think
about how they're doing, you know, as,
as your child is developing at language,
is there a nice tone of voice?
Are they owning that language?
Uh, you know, they are,
they able to not only read, come
here, but they too will do come here.
And you can especially teach that when
there's a couple of you. I, you know,
daddy come here.
Well you have to show him,
go do this and you can even do
a little here and I'll help you.
And you do come here Daddy. And
then, yeah. And then Daddy, oh,
thanks for showing me.
So again,
you thank him for whatever you want the,
the skill to improve on. So if
language is already there and you went,
the gestural reinforced
that gesture by the showing,
make expectations clear,
have that beginning, middle,
and end to everything you're teaching
and stick with it for a few rounds until
they're able to read it. It's a couple for
some kids, it's getting them to buy in,
making it fun.
And I have to sell that fun.
And so I keep doing it that same way
and that makes it really clear what it
looks like.
And for some other kids it's important
for them to observe it multiple times so
they know what their role is.
If I want a child to do fast,
what does it look like?
What does it sound like?
I'm defining that word even as I say
it, right? Fast test, test, test, test.
And probably my speed isn't like really
fast. It may not even change that much,
but I'm calling it fast and um,
the way I'm saying it's fast and
so I'm selling the fast concept.
Um, and so it's really important
to make those expectations.
I know you've seen that on a few slides
already, but we want them to step up,
make sure it's clear, um, and
to support the follow through.
So the same little boy, he would
have a bag and I would ask him to,
heavy work is really good
for a kid. Most kids too. Um,
and so I would have him bring the
bag inside and he would take the bag,
but he would take a couple steps and
Linda kind of slip off his arm and I do a
playful and obstruction and say,
wait, you know, to the door,
but I already made the expectation
clear, you know, to bring it to the door.
So whether it's groceries or whatever,
where do they have to carry it to,
to the table, to the door,
whatever, have it very clear.
And so I put it back on his arm and I
actually would held this arm up and said,
you know, I'll help you. And we go to the
door with it. And I said, good, you know,
good caring or good listening.
Um,
and then he started to do an himself
after a couple times of me holding it to
them cause I didn't,
I couldn't,
it wasn't an activity that I could in
that short amount of time repeat over and
over. He was getting there and I
just was having it carry to the door.
So after a few visits of that,
he knew that I was going to hold them
to it and he started doing it himself.
Um, if needed, allow
for sensory input break.
So if a kid's doing homework or whatever,
and you see them moving a
little more good, put language
shoe that, oh, I know us,
you're moving in your seat, or
your, your work's getting sloppy.
How about we jump three times
and then try again? You know, or,
um, a, but don't let them go watch TV or
do something that they're not coming back
from. It's that sensory input.
It's that movement. You know,
an article came out a few years ago now
and it was research showing that kids
who sit on a bouncy ball
are more successful, um,
in school, get higher grades,
doing homework on a bouncy ball.
And so having that movement
can really help with focus,
work and be animated.
You've seen that and there's your summary.
So, sorry if I sped through that last
part, but it's to get to questions.
Oh, I should just go right. Oh, there's
some resources at the end, by the way,
including all these resources.
You can additionally get through a spa.
And these Yahoo chat groups
for parents only, they vet it.
Well it's parents only.
You do not have to be on the peninsula
or Kaiser parents from all over.
Different insurances are in both and
they're strong advocate parents who run
those groups.
Okay. Um, we do have some
time for questions and um,
we'll take audience questions first and
we do have a microphone that will pass
around for those questions.
The audience questions.
Okay. Too much information
over. I'll go to the dory.
Thank you.
Okay. So the first question on the Dory
is what would you recommend as effective
methods for disciplining
children with autism?
You know, it depends on
the child. Certainly. Um,
you want to teach and get tilos yes.
Sides as much as possible. And so
certainly, uh, you know, for some kids,
timeout works given a
break. Well, you know,
but having them try again is very,
very important.
So if it's a child who pulls hair,
you know,
I used to run a center based program
and we had a little boy who would really
want it to play with these other kids
and he'd pull the little girl's hair.
And so teaching gentle hands,
oh you can say hi, you can pat.
And so we were right there at
teach what he could do, um,
with his hands to get that interaction
that we knew he wanted it. So you know,
what is the purpose of that behavior
and then looking for the replacements,
what are the yes in those,
because the know is pulling hair,
explaining that to a child,
why they can't pull hair and then the
friend won't want to play with them.
And all of this, for most kids that's
not going to teach what should I do?
And so teaching the, what should they
do? If you do a time out, you know,
you can say, okay, we're going to, we're
going to take a break and then try again.
Give them that opportunity to
try it again if it's at home,
but then help them be
successful as they try it again.
He went. Other Tory question. Um,
are there any resources that you would
recommend for parents of older children
who may not have the skill sets
initially to live on their own?
Specifically about job life skill
training and resources as well as possible
options such as group homes
or assisted living for adult?
Um,
so if you haven't contacted the
bay autism center in San Francisco,
run by,
um,
Jill Escher and she does a lot
of workshops as well or um,
sh Jill usher is really is putting a lot
of time and effort resources into uh,
older children,
individuals.
You can also call [inaudible] an s
book and give you a lot more resources.
If you want anything
specific, they can, um,
give you contacts and you know,
any information around
groups and all of that. Um,
there's a lot of apps out there
that I know are being used. Again,
if you call s she can kind of go over
some of those, uh, for work stuff
as well.
Okay. Any other audience
questions before we end?
Okay.
Your microphone's coming to you.
Um,
do you have any suggestions if your child
is a extremely food limiting as far as
their choices, as far as things to
kind of get them to open up to, uh,
to new foods and things?
Uh,
so that is certainly a hard one because
we get so scared of our kids not eating
that we many times will give over.
I mean,
and I know the specialists out there that,
that work with food issues
have long wait list. Um,
but a lot of,
and certainly you can call
Espa and Christina can give
you some information and
contact you with other people. Um,
there'd be no cost to it. Well we,
we recently did a four s ba I did,
I do parent groups as well. If you ever
want information on that, they're free to,
to attend and you can do remote
and in person. And one was on food.
And one of the tips that
this specialist gay,
which I thought was really interesting
is if your child say, is eating bread,
well you want to add just one thing that
compliments bread that you think will
be acceptable, like butter. You don't want
it then say, okay, here's spinach, right?
Whatever they are eating,
you want something that actually goes
with that item to just get a different
taste on the Palette, to just stretch them
up, different texture, different flavor,
um, that would be acceptable
for them to try. Um, but if you,
if you, um, I don't know
if my email's on here,
I can send you the presentation.
This individual did that
Hella nice tips in that too.
I'll give you an email with really,
do you have any recommendation for
when the kids start to act a silly,
especially in they're
comfortable with the situation.
Start like acting very
silly, very, very silly.
And a lot of that is, uh, uh, you know,
some underlying anxiety. We see that as,
or even being overstimulated.
So deep pressure helps with that.
I would put language to it, say, you know,
start to help them discriminate
when that's appropriate, when not,
if it doesn't feel like a connection,
it probably is overstimulation, right?
So depending on where you are,
sometimes holding a some item that they
can give pressure squeeze, you know,
those balls or whatever. Um, you know,
we used to put a weight, the,
the avoid the ankle weights.
You open those up and put it on a child's
lap and that will ground them a little
bit. Their feet should always be
touching the ground to be grounded.
If they're sitting in your chair,
you don't want their feet dangling because
then they'd have no way of grounding
themselves and they can kind
of start to get out of control.
Um, if it's somewhere where you're sitting
and you can put them on their lap and
give him some deep pressure
that can help, uh, just that PR,
even weight pressure on the shoulders
to relax their body and ground them,
but you want to hold and kind
of affirm hold and with, uh,
not that grabbed squeeze consequence
that can work them up even higher.
But just that like squeeze and hold and I,
I will,
I won't break contact and I
will do the rule of three.
So if I'm given a hug or something,
right for a child, they'll say, ah,
and there's my beginning,
you know,
hug and I get this nice deep
hug and then I will let up,
but I don't break contact and
I'll do it the rule of three
and I do it again and then I'll open up
and some kids will push back into me,
I'll say more ugh.
And it's just to relax their body.
Um, so that then we can have more focused
work or they can move on to something
else. Deep squeezes in the
hand really help. And I mean,
I get nice from school yet, and
again, I'll say she's queen.
And so that's where time where
I won't be, you know, when we,
when we talk about bringing that
energy, it's not being obnoxious, right?
Cause I can do it with no words are,
but for a child who's kind
of overstimulate, then yes,
it's kind of lowering it and giving
that deep pressure, you know,
kind of a whisper and con, let's try
squeeze is, and I'm always just trying.
I don't know what's going to work.
I'm taking best guests and squeeze,
and then I'm just relaxing their
body and then we try again.
Whatever situation is okay, now
let's try to watch, you know,
focus or whatever it is.
And I'll use the word focus quite a bit
because we want focus during certain
activities.
Yeah.
Okay. Thank you so much. You
want to thank you for attending.